sr spectators economics correspondent
kate andrews and the editor of
nottinghamshire live natalie fahey
lovely to see you this sunday evening
let's get cracking then it's going to be
a big week this week isn't it kate two
issues are going to dominate westminster
sue gray's report being published we
understand and also of course the cost
of living the front of the eye cost of
living help on hold as pm focuses on
party gate we don't yet know exactly
when the report is coming out it's
thought that it could be tuesday at the
earliest case
yes it's expected that sugar's report
will finally be released this week
the eye combines as you say jonathan the
two major issues that are going to
dominate the week but of course the cost
of living isn't just going to dominate
uh politics this week it's going to
dominate for the many weeks and very
likely months possibly even years to
come and i don't mean to be so negative
but the projections that we're looking
at the most recent ones from the bank of
england suggests that we have some very
difficult economic times ahead
but until we get over the political
hurdle of the secret report it is
difficult to fully focus on the cost of
living crisis
that is expected this week the question
is whether or not uh it is contained uh
whether or not it has explosive new
revelations in it uh if it doesn't then
perhaps it will uh truly stay contained
to this week if it does then perhaps
like the cost of living crisis we could
be talking about the ramifications of
the sea report for some time to come
yeah and kate just uh just very quickly
do you think this report could actually
be more damaging for the prime minister
than the fine he received given the the
detail that we're expecting it to go
into
it's certainly possible it's very
difficult to answer that question
without knowing what's in the report and
ultimately you know sue gray has the
real knowledge on that until this thing
is released um but at the moment the
fine that the prime minister received is
for the event that i think most people
would say they have no sympathy with
which was that he was quote ambushed by
cake meaning that he came into his
office and it was discovered that they
had a birthday cake for the prime
minister it was indeed against the rules
but generally speaking it's the one that
the public and most importantly for the
prime minister right now tory mps have
the most sympathy with uh if the secret
report finds that the prime minister
himself or his post allies and advisers
were much more heavily active in illegal
partying taking place in downing street
i do think it could cause them another
round of headaches that being said the
fact that the met believe the police
have now concluded their investigations
into these parties and have only issued
the prime minister with one fine puts
him on much steadier standing this week
than he otherwise would have had okay um
natalie i want to get your thoughts on
uh on the sue grey report and then i'm
going to ask you about the uh the front
page of the metro which is a a very
distressing headline um just
just give me your your your main
assessment of what you think we can
expect this week
well i mean
i think the problem is uh a lot of
people outside the westminster bubble
are actually starting to think now can
the government please get on with
sorting out uh you know the cost of
living crisis the price of energy bills
that just increasingly going up and up
and not with no end in sight we've heard
so much about partygate beergate now the
sue grey report um it just seems like
the government's incredibly distracted
at the moment which is said on the front
page of the eye here
and i think what people really want now
is just for them to get on with helping
people helping families so they can
afford their grocery bills um but you
know it's all being dragged up again and
i think once we actually get some
perspective on what happened over the
last couple of years
oh what a shame we seem to have have we
lost no don't carry on we've got your
connection back carry on natalie well i
tell you what why don't we bring the
metro in um
talking about um how people are
suffering with the cost of everything at
the moment and and they've got this
awful story brits feel the pinch there's
been a big rise in shoplifting they're
talking about one pensioner uh stealing
things like shampoo um someone who'd
never have thought of having to shoplift
before just in order to sort of survive
yeah it's absolutely devastating this i
mean it was kind of going to be always
going to be an obvious consequence of
the price of food going up um there's a
really awful line in there about people
having to make a choice between shampoo
and washing powder it's just absolutely
devastating and you can you can actually
picture this happening but it's just a
vicious cycle really because obviously
we all know that the cost of shoplifting
it means that retail businesses have to
put their prices up even more to cover
that
um i don't really know what the solution
is but it's absolutely devastating um
and what was trying to say before was
that um once we look back on these past
couple of years i think we'll see that
the kobit rules were you know ridiculous
over the top and probably quite a lot of
people are thinking now can we just move
on
you know because um boris johnson's been
fined the report's coming out but we are
having to stand in sainsbury's and make
a choice about whether we can buy
shampoo or washing powder and it's just
devastating yeah i think all the
priorities the roman country yeah that's
interesting that
kate do you think that do you think most
people in the country are ready to draw
a line under it and move on
i think many people are
and as natalie says their main focus
right now is how they pay the bills and
and the fact that many of the goods and
services that they could afford before
they're struggling to afford now i do
think that is the number one concern and
there is a real danger um and this is
actually probably the biggest danger for
opposition parties in westminster right
now is that nobody wants to be seen to
be playing politics when you know the
nitty-gritty of people's lives um is is
only becoming worse
that that i i you know maybe i am in the
minority here um i want as many details
as possible about what was happening
amongst the politicians who were setting
these rules during covet
who
allegedly and seemingly may have been
breaking some of them i think the more
information the public has about that
the better
not necessarily even for so-called
punishment or what happens now but for a
reminder in the future that one
government does set these extremely
draconian restrictions it is important
to remember that it's government that
also
can create the loophole so that people
at the top can work their way around
them and i just really think that is a
very important point to harp on as we
reflect on what we've all sacrificed
over the past two years yeah okay well
let's move on to what some of the
solutions might be for the cost of
living crisis because there's been a
huge amount of talk about the windfall
tax especially this weekend natalie
there does seem to be a split doesn't
there uh in uh in government about
whether or not it's the way to go kwazii
kwateng sajid javid brandon lewis all
against the windfall tax but there's
also talk about uh maybe some sort of
fudge that it could be brought in but in
quite a specific way
yeah that's right i mean there does seem
to be a lot of dithering about this i
mean again we're coming back to the
government being distracted they
probably just need to make a decision on
this um but obviously it would be a huge
concession to labor because it's
something they've proposed for a long
time but obviously the government has
sort of said well we don't really want
to do this at the moment
unfortunately for the government it
seems that this is what the public does
want
whether or not it will be a long-term
solution or not remains to be seen and
probably of the opinion that you know it
will help in the short term but
long-term solution it's not going to
help
so
you know
maybe relief for families this winter
but um not great news for the companies
and as it says there for people's
pension pots you know they'll have to
take money out of people's pension pots
to be able to afford it
kate where do you stand on the windfall
tax
personally i think it's a very bad idea
i think the principle in and of itself
that uh the government can come in and
do a tax raid um because times are tough
is a dangerous one to send and and every
company every individual should be
thinking about what that could mean
under a different government and under
different circumstances it is very
telling that the chancellor has never
rolled out a windfall tax he has always
left that window slightly open um and he
is a chancellor who if you were to bring
forward another support package would
not want to be borrowing all of that
money so would be looking for how he
might pay for something um whilst the
energy price cap does not go up again
until october it's so clear from the
front page of the metro and countless
other costs of living headlines across
the newspapers that people are really
feeling that pain now so let's not be
surprised uh you know if we see
announcements sooner rather than later
about another round of support packages
but let's also not forget
that the chancellor pledged nine billion
pounds as recently as february to
helping people with their energy bills
and one of the very top realities about
inflation
is that once you start spiraling it's
very difficult to control and while
there are levers that government can
pull and there are temporary handouts
that can help these are going to be
really difficult times that we are not
going to be able to cushion every single
blow that comes our way and i don't
think that this was ever properly warned
about or discussed throughout the copa
crisis and and even in the months where
things were getting better um that there
were always going to be consequences
to shutting down the global economy
multiple times kick-starting again and
then on top of that you have russia's
aggression against ukraine skyrocketing
energy food prices and
it's been a perfect perfect storm hasn't
it natalie let's talk about this story
on the front of the telegraph i mean if
this is true it's desperately worrying
isn't it that the nhs waiting list may
be twice as long as have been reported
this is all down to
how it's been counted
yeah it it's desperately worrying but
i'm not surprised and i doubt anyone
else will be watching tonight either or
reading the article um it's supposed to
be something like one in five people are
actually on nhs waiting lists waiting
for treatment so about 13 million that's
what i've read um
i mean you know for many months people
were too scared to go into hospitals
because they thought they might catch
clovid or you know they stayed at home
suffering instead and i think it's only
now that we're starting to see the
fallout from that i i
we need some kind of intervention
in order for the nhs to catch up and to
get these waiting lists down um i i
don't know i'm not too sure about the
way things are counted because you know
i think you've got to be a health expert
to be able to um properly comment on
that but it's incredibly complicated and
the facts that you know a few million
extra people have just sort of been
discovered shows you what a complete
mess it's in i'm not really sure what
the solution is um
but what i do know is that you can't get
a doctor's appointment at my local
surgery um if my children are ill they
have to speak to
my partner how to speak to gp over the
phone they do a video or phone
consultation you can't just walk into
your gp and see them anymore and it's
all starting there at the local gp level
um in lincolnshire where i live they're
closing down uh accident emergency units
they are moving essential services
centralizing things so you have to
travel further in order to get to places
and all of that just puts extra strain
on the nhs and uh you know those 13
million people i'm i'm pretty sure that
we might see that number even go up
actually yeah um and it's not only a
crisis with the waiting list kate it's a
crisis with children's mental health as
well
yeah um very upsetting headline on the
front page of guardian that more than
400 000 children and young people
uh are seeking treatment for mental
health problems and that number has
risen by 52 since february 2020 ie just
before we went into lockdown and this is
connected to the nhs story these are the
unintended consequences of the decisions
that were taken um during covet
not just to lock down but to have some
of the longest lockdowns in europe
especially
that one that essentially lasts between
christmas 2020 and summer 2021
and the backlogs that have been created
by that but also the long-term
ramifications for mental health and
physical health that have been created
by that we are going to be dealing with
not just for years but for decades of
course the nhs has been given
billions and billions of pounds to catch
up already in the form of that national
insurance hike that all workers are now
paying as people to get more cash into
the system